era un lugar que aún era pobre,
todavía segregado,
todavía dramáticamente en necesidad de cambio.
Mi escuela, donde fui asignada,
no tenía biblioteca, ni consejero,
pero sí tenía un oficial de policía.
La mitad de los profesores eran suplentes
y cuando los estudiantes se metían en peleas,
la escuela los enviaba a la cárcel local del condado.
Esta es la escuela donde conocí a Patrick.
Tenía 15 años y se retrasó dos veces, estaba en octavo grado.
Era tranquilo, introspectivo,
como metido siempre en un pensamiento profundo.
Y odiaba ver pelear a otras personas.
Lo vi saltar una vez entre dos chicas cuando se metieron en una pelea
y él mismo se tiró al suelo.
Patrick tenía un solo problema.
No venía a la escuela.
Decía que a veces la escuela era demasiado deprimente.
porque la gente siempre estaba peleando y los maestros renunciaban.
Y su madre tenía dos trabajos y estaba demasiado cansada para hacerlo venir.
Así que hice mi trabajo para que viniera a la escuela.
Y porque estaba loca y de 22 años y celosamente optimista,
mi estrategia fue solo presentarme en su casa.
y decir: "Oye, ¿por qué no vienes a la escuela?".
Y esta estrategia realmente funcionó,
Empezó a venir a la escuela todos los días.
Y comenzó a florecer en mi clase.
Estaba escribiendo poesía, estaba leyendo libros.
Venía a la escuela todos los días.
Casi al mismo tiempo
que había descubierto cómo conectarme con Patrick,
entré en la escuela de derecho en Harvard.
Una vez más me enfrenté a esta pregunta, ¿dónde debería ponerme?
¿Dónde pongo mi cuerpo?
Y pensé para mí misma.
que el Delta del Mississippi era un lugar de donde las personas con dinero,
la gente con oportunidad,
esas personas, se van.
Y las personas que se quedan atrás
son las personas que no tienen la oportunidad de irse.
No quería ser una persona que se iba.
Quería ser una persona que se quedaba.
Por otro lado, estaba sola y cansada.
Y así me convencí de que podría hacer más cambios.
en una escala más grande si tuviera un prestigioso título de abogada.
Así que me fui.
Tres años despues,
cuando estaba a punto de graduarme de la escuela de leyes,
mi amigo me llamó
y me dijo que Patrick se había metido en una pelea y había matado a alguien.
Estaba devastada.
Parte de mí no lo creía,
pero una parte de mí también sabía que era verdad.
Volé hacia allá para ver a Patrick.
Lo visité en la cárcel.
Y me dijo que era verdad.
Que había matado a alguien.
Y no quería hablar más de eso.
Le pregunté qué había pasado con la escuela
y me dijo que había abandonado el año después de que me fui.
Y luego quiso decirme algo más.
Miró hacia abajo y dijo que había tenido una hija
que acaba de nacer.
Y sintió que la había decepcionado.
Eso fue todo, nuestra conversación fue apresurada y torpe.
Cuando salí de la cárcel, una voz dentro de mí dijo:
"Vuelve.
Si no vuelves ahora, nunca volverás".
Así que me gradué de la escuela de derecho y volví.
Volví a ver a Patrick,
Regresé para ver si podía ayudarlo con su caso legal.
Y esta vez, cuando lo vi por segunda vez,
pensé que tenía esta gran idea, dije,
"Oye, Patrick, ¿por qué no le escribes una carta a tu hija,
para que puedas tenerla en tu mente?
Y le di un bolígrafo y un trozo de papel,
y comenzó a escribir.
Pero cuando vi el papel que me devolvió,
me quedé impactada.
No reconocí su letra,
había cometido simples errores de ortografía.
Y pensé que como maestra,
sabía que un estudiante podría mejorar dramáticamente
en un tiempo muy rápido,
pero nunca pensé que un estudiante pudiera retroceder dramáticamente.
Lo que incluso me dolió más,
fue ver lo que le había escrito a su hija.
Había escrito,
"Lo siento por mis errores, lo siento por no estar ahí para ti".
Y esto era todo lo que sentía que tenía que decirle a ella.
Y me pregunté cómo puedo convencerlo de que tiene más que decir,
partes de sí mismo de las que no necesita disculparse.
Quería que él se sintiera
que tenía algo que valía la pena compartir con su hija.
Cada día de los siguientes siete meses,
lo visité y le llevé libros.
Mi bolso de mano se convirtió en una pequeña biblioteca.
Llevé a James Baldwin,
Llevé a Walt Whitman, CS Lewis.
Llevé guías de árboles, de aves,
y el que sería su libro favorito, el diccionario.
Algunos días,
nos sentábamos por horas en silencio, los dos leyendo.
Y otros días,
leíamos juntos, leíamos poesía.
Comenzamos leyendo haikus, cientos de haikus,
una obra maestra engañosamente simple.
Y le pedía: "Comparte conmigo tus haikus favoritos".
Y algunos son bastante divertidos.
Así que hay esto por Issa:
"No te preocupes, arañas, mantengo la casa casualmente".
Y esto: "Duerme la mitad del día, nadie me castigó!".
Y esta hermosa, que es sobre el primer día de nieve,
"Ciervos que se lamen la primera escarcha de los abrigos del otro".
Hay algo misterioso y hermoso.
justo como se ve un poema.
El espacio vacío es tan importante como las propias palabras.
Leímos este poema de WS Merwin,
que escribió después de ver a su esposa trabajando en el jardín.
y se dieron cuenta de que pasarían el resto de sus vidas juntos.
"Déjame imaginar que vendremos otra vez
cuando queramos y sea primavera
No seremos más viejos que nunca
Los desgastados dolores se habrán aliviado como la nube temprana
a través de la cual la mañana viene lentamente".
Le pregunté a Patrick cuál era su verso favorito, y dijo:
"No seremos más viejos que nunca".
Dijo que le recordaba un lugar en el que el tiempo simplemente se detiene,
donde el tiempo ya no importa
Y le pregunté si tenía un lugar así.
en el que el tiempo durara para siempre.
Y dijo: "Mi madre".
Cuando lees un poema junto a alguien más,
el poema cambia de significado.
Porque se vuelve personal para esa persona, se vuelve personal para ti.
Luego leímos libros, leímos tantos libros,
Leímos las memorias de Frederick Douglass,
Un esclavo estadounidense que aprendió a leer y escribir
y que escapó a la libertad por su alfabetización.
Había crecido pensando en Frederick Douglass como un héroe,
y pensé en esta historia como una de elevación y esperanza.
Pero este libro puso a Patrick en una especie de pánico.
Se fijó en una historia que Douglass contó sobre cómo, durante la Navidad,
los amos daban ginebra a los esclavos
como una forma de demostrarles que no podían manejar la libertad.
Porque los esclavos tropezarían en los campos.
Patrick dijo que se relacionaba con esto.
Dijo que hay personas en la cárcel que, como esclavos,
no quieren pensar en su condición,
porque es muy doloroso.
Demasiado doloroso pensar en el pasado,
demasiado doloroso pensar en lo lejos que tenemos que ir.
Su línea favorita era esta:
"¡Cualquier cosa, no importa qué, para deshacerse del pensamiento!
Fue este pensamiento eterno de mi condición lo que me atormentó".
Patrick dijo que Douglass era valiente por escribir, por seguir pensando.
Pero Patrick nunca sabría cuánto se me parecía él a Douglass.
Cómo siguió leyendo, a pesar del pánico.
Terminó el libro antes que yo,
leyéndolo en una escalera de hormigón sin luz.
Y luego continuamos leyendo uno de mis libros favoritos,
"Galaad" de Marilynne Robinson
que es una carta extendida de un padre a su hijo.
Le encantó esta línea:
"Estoy escribiendo esto en parte para contarte
que si alguna vez te preguntaste lo que has hecho en tu vida...
tú has sido la gracia de Dios para mí.
Un milagro, algo más que un milagro".
Algo sobre este lenguaje, su amor, su anhelo, su voz,
reavivó el deseo de Patrick de escribir.
Y llenó cuadernos y más cuadernos
con cartas a su hija.
En estas bellas e intrincadas cartas,
se imaginaba a él y a su hija yendo en canoa por el río Mississippi.
Se imaginaba los dos encontrando un arroyo en la montaña
con agua perfectamente clara.
Mientras miraba a Patrick escribir,
pensé para mí misma,
y ahora les pregunto a todos,
¿cuántos han escrito una carta a alguien que sienten que han decepcionado?
Es mucho más fácil sacar a esas personas de tu mente.
Pero Patrick aparecía todos los días, enfrentando a su hija,
responsabilizándose de ella,
Palabra por palabra con intensa concentración.
Yo queria en mi propia vida
ponerme en riesgo de esa manera.
Porque ese riesgo revela la fuerza del corazón.
Déjenme dar un paso atrás y solo hacerles una pregunta incómoda.
¿Quién soy yo para contar esta historia, como en esta historia de Patrick?
Patrick es el que vivió con este dolor
y yo no he tenido hambre ni un día en mi vida.
Pensé mucho en esta pregunta,
pero lo que quiero decir es que esta historia no es solo sobre Patrick.
Es sobre nosotros,
Se trata de la desigualdad entre nosotros.
El mundo de la abundancia
del que Patrick y sus padres y sus abuelos
han sido excluidos.
En esta historia, represento ese mundo de abundancia.
Y al contar esta historia, no quería esconderme.
Oculta el poder que tengo.
Al contar esta historia, quise exponer ese poder.
y luego preguntar,
¿cómo disminuimos la distancia entre nosotros?
La lectura es una forma de cerrar esa distancia.
Nos da un universo tranquilo que podemos compartir juntos,
que podemos compartir por igual.
Probablemente se estén preguntando ahora qué le pasó a Patrick.
¿Le salvó la vida la lectura?
Lo hizo y no lo hizo.
Cuando Patrick salió de la cárcel,
su viaje fue insoportable.
Los empleadores lo rechazaron debido a su historial,
su mejor amiga, su madre, murió a los 43 años
de enfermedades del corazón y diabetes.
Ha estado sin hogar, ha tenido hambre.
La gente dice muchas cosas sobre la lectura que me parecen exageradas.
Ser alfabetizado no le impidió ser discriminado.
No impidió que su madre muriera.
Entonces, ¿qué puede hacer la lectura?
Tengo algunas respuestas con las que terminar hoy.
La lectura cargaba su vida interior
con misterio, con imaginación,
con belleza.
La lectura le dio imágenes que le dieron alegría:
montaña, océano, venado, escarcha.
Palabras que saben a un mundo libre y natural.
La lectura le dio un lenguaje para lo que había perdido.
¿Qué preciosas son estas líneas del poeta Derek Walcott?
Patrick memorizó este poema.
"Días que he celebrado,
días que he perdido,
días que crecen, como hijas,
mis brazos albergados".
La lectura le enseñó su propio coraje.
Recuerden que seguía leyendo a Frederick Douglass,
aunque fuera doloroso.
Siguió siendo consciente, a pesar de que la conciencia duele.
La lectura es una forma de pensar,
por eso es difícil leer porque tenemos que pensar.
Y Patrick optó pensar, en lugar de no pensar.
Y por último, la lectura le dio un lenguaje para hablarle a su hija.
La lectura lo inspiró a querer escribir.
El enlace entre la lectura y la escritura es muy poderoso.
Cuando empezamos a leer,
empezamos a encontrar las palabras.
Y el encontró las palabras para imaginarse a los dos juntos.
Encontró las palabras
para decirle cuánto la amaba.
La lectura también cambió nuestra relación.
Nos dio una ocasión para la intimidad,
para ver más allá de nuestros puntos de vista.
Y la lectura tomó una relación desigual
y nos dio una igualdad momentánea.
Cuando conoces a alguien como lector,
te encuentras con él por primera vez,
nuevamente, recientemente.
No hay manera de que puedas saber cuál será su línea favorita.
Qué recuerdos y dolores privados tiene.
Y te enfrentas a la máxima privacidad de su vida interior.
Y luego empiezas a preguntarte: "Bueno, ¿de qué está hecha mi vida interior?
¿Qué tengo que valga la pena compartir con otro?".
Quiero cerrar
con algunas de mis líneas favoritas de las cartas de Patrick a su hija.
"El río está en sombra en algunos lugares.
Pero la luz brilla a través de las grietas de los árboles...
En algunas ramas cuelgan un montón de moras.
Extiendes el brazo para agarrar unas pocas".
Y esta preciosa carta, donde escribe,
"Cierra los ojos y escucha los sonidos de las palabras.
Conozco este poema de memoria
y me gustaría que lo supieras, también".
Muchísimas gracias a todos.
(Aplausos)